hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and just check it in on you just
check it in on you there's a lot of
smiling faces out there today despite me
the situation we're currently and where
everybody's still [ __ ] eating and
actually a lot of people gaining weight
a lot of people
stress eating when I get upset I coffee
cake I just I don't know what it is I
think when I was a little girl
any time I started to cry because my dad
wasn't there my mother would just take
coffee cake and just shove it down my
Bible and ever since then I've just had
this muffin top I know just if you could
just like slice along here and dice
along there I just think then then I'll
be happy I don't want to work on myself
as a person I just want you to slice
away some of the fat all right there was
a lot of happy men in the United States
of America specifically football fans
and I am a big enough man to
congratulate all of them congratulations
to New York jet fans congratulations
congratulations to the Miami Dolphin
fans although you did pretty good
against them Pittsburgh Steeler fans
come on man you know you having a great
morning Kansas City chief fans come on
you know it you know it in fact
congratulations to all football fans in
the AFC other than New England Patriots
fans because Tom Brady is no longer in
the AFC he is now in the NFC all right
although one division is going to have
to deal with interleague play you know
but there'll be plenty of good seats
after this pandemic explodes or whatever
the [ __ ] they're trying to tell you on
these 24-hour news networks anyway Tom
Brady science with the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers and as a New England Patriot
fan who saw him way back to Jim Plunkett
I just have to say thank you for 20
seasons of the greatest quarterback I've
ever seen
I get the move I get the move down to
Florida I get it it's what every old
white guy in Massachusetts after a while
gets sick of the winter and gets sick of
paying state taxes and they go down to
Florida and they don't go to Miami okay
they go down to [ __ ] where the what
the [ __ ] is it oh Jesus Christ it's just
south of Tampa I forget what the [ __ ]
it's called they always end up down
there they end up on the [ __ ] west
coast they know they never seem to end
up in like Miami you know it's always in
now what the fine I'll keep thinking
Corpus Christi but that's Texas what the
[ __ ] is I don't know what it is but he's
down there he's not paying any state
taxes right he's gonna get all tanned up
for the broadcast both he's probably
looking at Tony Romo like that son of a
[ __ ] you mean that guy that [ __ ] guy
with no [ __ ] rings this guy's is
making this money to talk football I'm
gonna go down there and get tanned up
like [ __ ] John F Kennedy right before
he debated [ __ ] Richard Nixon on the
news and I'm gonna roll my way right
into a broadcasting job Florida map all
right let's see what am I trying to
think here let's see here
Florida what's the name of Jesus I want
a map is it so hard when you type in
Florida map to get a map of Florida
there we go
there it is I always blame the computer
and as a comedian I always blame the
crowd all right I always blame my wife
and that's all you really need to know
for me are you just gonna give me Tampa
you [ __ ] [ __ ] all right here we go
what the [ __ ] is it okay where is it
come on don't be shy don't be shy why I
don't understand why it won't work maybe
because I'm in a rush what is going on
with elf I don't give a [ __ ] anymore
I'll remember it later on in the podcast
anyways haha
they did the [ __ ] things never work
for me I don't get it yesterday I was
doing a it's writing on f is for family
via Skype and everybody's like I'll just
sign into this and download this app
it's really easy and so somebody's
walking me through it I click on the
[ __ ] thing and then they're just like
okay now this should be a window that
says press the easy button and it's just
like yeah it's not there well that's
interesting
that's interesting so anyway yeah I
think he's uh it's got some good great
wide receivers down there it's a
definitely interesting choice for Tom
but I mean to not pay state income tax
is [ __ ] huge you're in your last year
and and that's it so I mean what are you
gonna do what are you gonna do the guy
wanted six Super Bowls you know and
defense at Tom he should have at least
eight okay you know I mean what are you
supposed to do when you know what are
you supposed to do if somebody drops an
interception or somebody you know that
there's [ __ ] three punts in a game is
that his fault I don't think it is
always drove us down the field he was
[ __ ] right there so yeah I don't
think it's really hit me it's seen
seeing the Patriots without Tom Brady is
gonna be like it's gonna be like seeing
the Yankees without Jeter
number how weird that was for a while
I'm just looking out there and he just
wasn't there but it is what it is it's
also one of the amazing things I think
that also adds to the drama of sports is
that these guys even Oh Brady's 42 they
they it just you see the beginning the
middle in the end and you see him go
from a young guy to the you know
experienced guy to the veteran to you
know I don't with Brady though he always
looks good to me but you know getting
you know ready to get in towards the end
just the drama of that I just don't
understand why people choose to watch
reality TV
assisted reality rather
and watching - I don't know maybe
because sports it dumb who the [ __ ]
knows but anyways thank you Tom Brady
and then fellow Patriots fans don't
listen to sports talk radio and they're
just gonna come up with a bunch of soap
opera [ __ ] you know they'll oh he didn't
get along with this person he banged
this person this person did this and
that the other [ __ ] Tom Brady bent
over backwards he restructured his
contract I don't know how many times we
get the players we needed and then he
delivered in the big moments he's going
down there to get paid and that [ __ ]
pay any state tax good for him good for
him I hope he has a great offensive line
I hope the [ __ ] Buccaneers win it
that would be incredible be incredible
personally I was hoping he was going to
go to San Francisco because I know he
grow I know that he grew up out there
and that was his team and he loved Joe
Montana and be pretty cool to see be the
first quarterback to win Super Bowl
number six for a franchise with two
different teams nobody's ever done that
that would have been a cool thing and
congratulations to Tampa Bay Buccaneer
fence you got to be [ __ ] excited I bet
you know even though you are quarantined
I bet you ran a creative resist the urge
to run across the street and hug another
fat Floridian with a pirate shirt on
alright so that's that that is the deal
I've been having a great time with my
self quarantine how about you guys what
are you working on I am playing the best
drums of my life that's like I'm I feel
like I'm a little kid again living at
home with my parents with like no
[ __ ] job and I can just go down go
downstairs into the basement and play
drums for two hours I know a couple
other buddies of mine that play like
dude I'm really getting good at guitar
you know so this is the time people okay
without a pandemic and what are you
gonna do huh you're gonna listen to what
the [ __ ] they say but then that doesn't
mean you can't be having a good time
alright why don't you learn something
you always want learn how to caramelize
an onion you can [ __ ] find one with
all these scared [ __ ] going out of
the [ __ ] store every ten minutes how
often is the food still gonna have to be
coming they're still collecting
trash mail is still being delivered
you're still getting water to your house
you're fine
[ __ ] relax all right here's one for
you always wanted to shave your head but
you were afraid what people were going
to say now's the time to do it I've
begun a stretching program too there's
always been a couple of stretches that I
just when I went back in the day when I
was a younger man I'd actually go to a
yoga class right and I had a little
orange [ __ ] what a man bun no I did
my hair don't we just grew up I remember
I would see people being able to do
these stretches like just say that the
Cobra stretch like how the [ __ ] is your
spine double-jointed I didn't understand
it was my so ass all this [ __ ] in the
front and then the other one was when
you sit down with your legs out 45
degrees and then someone could just go
straight down and I thought that that
was another thing I thought it was your
back and I didn't realize that that was
your hamstring so I just been working on
that type of stuff this would you know
this great stretching routine and now
when I play drums my back doesn't bug me
anymore
like if you ever see a drummer and they
have like the back of a chair on their
drum throne if they have that back
support thing on the back it's just like
they need they need help okay cuz all
they're doing is they're just they're
playing to the symptoms as far as just
like you know now I'll have a [ __ ]
cane as opposed to working out and doing
physical therapy
I'm not saying everybody's like that but
I just I have noticed that like someone
helps few of my favorite drummers when I
see them when they get the back thing on
then I'm like oh no it's for back
support was strengthen your back muscles
you know you're in your 50s it's not too
late right it's never too late right
steak up there's a whole bunch of things
you'd be getting better an instrument
[ __ ] download rosetta stone
alright come back totally fluent with
your [ __ ] head shaved playing like
[ __ ] Eddie Van Halen then all the
chicks at the office are gonna be
standing six feet away from you being
like oh my god who is that
you know he got even stronger during a
pandemic they need justic type taps into
that cave woman in a he's a provider
he's gonna fight off that saber tooth
tiger and next thing you know you're
having a Corona 19 virus whatever the
[ __ ] it's called Conad [ __ ] 19 like
virus for a threesome it's gonna go down
why don't you come back a new [ __ ]
man
all right you head shaved like you're in
the [ __ ] road warrior okay
shredding guitar caramelizing onions
flexible you know relaxed get yourself a
nice little tan just come back looking
like you went to the [ __ ] Virgin
Islands or you can sit there like a
little scared [ __ ] squirrel that hurt
a goddamn noise and you can sit there
any dairy and candy and all this comfort
food as you watch 24-hour news networks
scaring the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of you by
the way the more I think about that hand
sanitizer guy he completely [ __ ] up he
should have talked [ __ ]
do you realize the [ __ ] balls it took
six weeks ago to spend 18 grand on hand
sanitizer betting that this thing all
these toys people said it finally was
bad you don't think he tried to get
other people to go and with them hey you
want to take your life savings and put
it into hand sanitizer because I think
this time next month we're gonna be
locked down people [ __ ] and the guy
[ __ ] does it and it pays off and they
take it away from him
like when Japan defeated Russia and they
went in to claim their land and then all
the white countries
settle down it's not our works and Japan
should have been like that is how it
works the hand sanitizer guys should be
that is how it [ __ ] works this is not
what this country is about this country
was built on genocide in slavery and we
don't do things like that what are you
talking about the [ __ ] are you talking
about
he went apology mode it was like
watching a comedian who didn't do
anything wrong and then apologized and
it just makes me nauseous the fact that
he came out there and he wore a family
man t-shirt that that was it that was it
then what he did was say that what all
of these people said that he did that
they were right that's what he should
have been like [ __ ] you you know you
24-hour news network you're the one out
here scaring the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of
people all right
you scared me too and I made an
offensive move and it [ __ ] paid off
and now you're gonna [ __ ] throw up
send me back 20 [ __ ] yards and
everybody's gonna judge me like I'm the
bad guy
the only thing he [ __ ] up was he got
too greedy other than that man it was
the [ __ ] move the man made the right
[ __ ] move and they took it away from
him took it away from and then everybody
got all self-righteous all these [ __ ]
liberal [ __ ] that went down to the
[ __ ] grocery store right and bought
up all the [ __ ] butter they could
carry knowing that they could carry more
food than a [ __ ] old person right
that's it
shout out to all the terrible parents
out there who allowed their kids to go
down to Spring Break
like how uninvolved of you as a parent
that you allowed that to happen and they
so don't even respect your [ __ ]
authority that they're actually on TV
doing interviews huh how much did you
spoil them as children terrible I'm
judging you right now terrible terrible
[ __ ] parents gonna Pat myself on the
back right now our daughter just took a
major
major step she's out of diapers she's
out of pull-ups all right not saying
there won't be a couple of accidents
here over the next couple of weeks but
she's she's about 90% potty-trained I
gotta tell you it's the Pratt this is
probably selfish of me but it's the most
proud I've been as a parent I went out
last night right I went to a crowded bar
and just started licking things and
afterwards when I came back no I do I do
a late night hike when nobody's around I
just walk around my neighborhood I just
walk around the block I walk around and
if anybody comes at me I'd literally
just go out in the street and I always
make the joke I go hey six feet six feet
and nobody ever laughs only a couple
people laugh it's like can we have
Christ I'm in the middle of the [ __ ]
street here so when I came back I went
came into the house one of my favorite
things to do to come back home see my
two lovely ladies and I come home I hear
my daughter jumping up and down
screaming upstairs and my wife hears me
come through the door and she's like
daddy guess what your daughter did and I
was like no way
no wait you know yeah she hit for this
cycle I don't want to get gross here but
she hit for the cycle on the [ __ ] and
she was jumping up and down I was
jumping up and down and I was like
sweetheart I am so proud of you I've
never seen her smile like that because
she's never seen like how happy she made
us and then we came down stand I said
you know what happens now right yeah she
goes downstairs she got a popsicle I
know you guys he's gonna reward her with
sweets every once in a while we don't
have to read a lot of sweets we actually
haven't eaten very well we're Hollywood
parents we have her on an alternative da
no we don't I I kind of like straddle
the line between the New Age thing and
hey let her have a [ __ ] burger right
not a lot of screen time but you know
let's watch it let's watch a Disney
classic or something like that oh by the
way we watched brave the other night
what
was a Pixar movie that I I didn't even
see when it came out you know I didn't
have any kids I wasn't married when it
came out so now all of these movies are
in my wheelhouse and shout out to the
great Billy Connelly when the greatest
stand-up comedians of all time did an
amazing job doing uh one of the voices I
don't know the name my daughter was
talking the whole time but guy without
you know missing the leg and such a
great movie and I went on Wikipedia and
I actually mean you need to kill some
time go read Billy Connolly's Wikipedia
page I mean it's like 19 pages and none
of it is not absolutely 100% riveting
Jesus Christ what a life that guy had
and the fact that he came out of all of
that and just was this great storyteller
you know that went around and made
everybody laugh and my I got to see him
with my wife in New York City back in
the 2000s and it was unbelievably did
two hours just went up there and was
just this [ __ ] force of nature just
one story led into the next story I
don't think I looked at my watch until
90 minutes in and I was looking down
going like what time this can't go
warranty like I just did like an hour
and a half I feel like I've been here
for 20 minutes
so I guess he's retired now from
performing which i think is awesome you
know I know he has some health issues or
whatever but his mind is still there
everything that I read and all of that
type of stuff but like who gives a [ __ ]
you guys 77 years old it's [ __ ] great
you know what I mean how many times can
you go to a goddamn Airport or maybe I'm
projecting you know because I am
enjoying this pandemic and not going to
the LAX all right I love what LAX has
done for my life but I hate going to the
[ __ ] thing and the fact that the
design the design of it is so [ __ ] up
and they are just so they can't shut it
down it's too far
can busy and they can't correct the
[ __ ] thing that they just have to
keep it's like the foundation is [ __ ]
up and they just keep adding more floors
on top of it so they're doing what they
are doing
continuing on and always an experience
always an experience here is a Idzik you
know what I usually don't give away
travel tips like this but I'm gonna do
it anyway
because I think mostly you will forget
this by the end of this [ __ ] here's
a great travel tip for you as far as LA
goes people either want to get the [ __ ]
out of here or they want to try to you
know have one more beach day so the key
is if you if your flight leaves around
one o'clock in the afternoon it's
[ __ ] great
as great as LAX can be try to leave
around 1:00 in the afternoon to three
o'clock [ __ ] perfect alright anything
before 11:00 is gonna be a [ __ ] show it
does start to slow down after 10:30 but
11:00 still pretty bad and then after
three four five it starts becoming a
[ __ ] show again plus you're also driving
over during like rush hour traffic you
start getting involved in that type of
[ __ ] but you get that one in the
afternoon flight
oh it's love it's a lovely experience
you glide through security
it's [ __ ] tremendous anyway so you
know something I've been doing while
I've been out here quarantine II myself
other than just working on [ __ ] drums
and you guys know the song that I've
been working on it's the song I've been
[ __ ] working on since I first started
playing drums good times bad times every
time we get close I get I get really
busy it's just like flying helicopters
same thing every time I feel like I
could solo and take out a passenger you
know take them a passenger up with me
blah blah blah blah blah then I'll get
an acting gig or just a bunch of road
work and then my skills drop and I
continue to fly with an instructor or I
[ __ ] get frustrated with drums and I
move on to something else but this time
I'm sticking with it you know that
little cute little girl who [ __ ]
played the song
perfectly just really inspired me I was
just like alright no more excuses bill
yes she doesn't have a job yes she
doesn't have to pay rent okay but how
petty we get in here she's 8 years old
and she can do it you can do it too
so thank you to her for showing me what
is possible here to see an adult do it
I'm just like alright they had the gift
bla bla bla bla bla but I know that girl
has gifts but she's also 8 years old and
she figured out how to do it so come on
so anyway I've been watching a bunch of
like old NHL classics and there's one
called the Good Friday Massacre now come
on even if you're not a [ __ ] sports
fan you got to watch this the Good
Friday Massacre 1984 playoffs and it's
the Quebec Nordiques versus the Montreal
Canadiens and it's in the Old Montreal
Forum well it's the second forum the one
I actually went to a game that one I
always tell you about March of 89 I saw
him against the Minnesota North Stars
and oh my god even just seeing that
arena and hearing the sound of that
arena
I got like sick to my stomach because
there was so many heartbreaking Bruins
lost we just couldn't no we couldn't we
couldn't even win a regular-season game
in there for like [ __ ] 15 years and
the Montreal Canadiens were the Montreal
Canadiens and I think the referees went
in there they were intimidated they were
afraid of the crowd and there was like
this [ __ ] unwritten rule that if the
Canadians were down a goal and there was
five minutes left if you even looked at
a Canadian they were going to get
[ __ ] put on a power play
it was [ __ ] ridiculous so I've been
watching this in it just it's called the
massacre not because of the score it was
just the amount of [ __ ] fights it was
just insane and I gotta be honest I
really missed the hockey to just the
stick handling it's just in the 80s were
the best there's the perfect time for
the goalscorer finesse people and the
[ __ ] some of the toughest guys who
ever played the game and also I saw one
before this I watched this one maybe
it's the one here I'll just scroll back
here there was one with 1975 Olds
Cutlass supreme three
50 v8 with swivel bucket seats he not
checking [ __ ] like this out although I
like the front end on the 77 better 4 4
2 t top with the 350 v8 that is a badass
[ __ ] car there was one I watched
where the Canadians with Larry Robinson
beat the Toronto Maple Leafs and the
Leafs were like hey look really quickly
Dave Taylor was being a maniac and in
the end he was going after the referee
and Larry Robinson came over and calmed
him down what a class act man he could
have just made let him you know lose his
emotions there but he didn't he [ __ ]
was that come on man I didn't worth it
just [ __ ] this isn't what we do here
it's not disrespect the game even though
we just beat the [ __ ] out of each other
for the last 60 minutes all right
the lovely Nia is here hey how you doing
I got a read oh my god the the I hope
you guys signed up for this thing
because you don't have to the most
perfect advertiser during a pandemic Nia
butcher box butcher box when it comes to
me what are you doing over there
what are you doing you brought snacks
Nia we're supposed to be conserving food
I don't think they're ever gonna bring
anything more all right come over here
oh right okay all right I'll let you get
settled see if it was a guy he just come
in sit down pick up the microphone but
all these brats nothing
what do you shut what are you holding up
[Music]
yeah but that was because there was mold
in here is that what we need exact math
you're supposed to have you have n95 my
just casually city yeah well that was
because there was mold world's bird
yesterday here horny with your two I got
those cuz men when they was mold in the
bottom of that so we went away in
vacation came back that was mold in the
bottom of the toilet seat and I had to
get it off but these are these are the
masks but I mean they're really for for
people who like work in the hospitals
and stuff like that but yeah this is
what you saw I tried to order some and
of course I couldn't get them oh wow
look at that so there you go and we got
two of them here in Brighton yeah now
you just made us a target all right put
your box everybody on them for $500 $500
I'm a family man when it comes to meat
quality matters but there's more to it
than texture and taste what's your
favorite cut of meat at this point
whatever I can get how do you like to
prepare it I actually you know what I
like I like the the heritage breed pork
grill cast iron skillet broiled how do
you like to do it you know I like to do
it
I [ __ ] brown it up in the skillet
then I finish it in the oven take it out
and then I give it a little garlic
rosemary butter bath spoon it over there
tremendous not everyone has convenient
access to high quality meat Jesus Christ
is this copies hilarious now luckily
there's butcher bucks butcher bucks
believes everyone deserves high-quality
humanely sourced me talk about how easy
it is to have butcher bucks meat just
show up at your door as compared to
fighting all those lunatics down at the
grocery store it's one of the greatest
things ever it's the greatest thing ever
this is this is what you need you need
this more than ever never be without
something to cook for dinner because
there's always meat in the freezer
one less trip to the grocery store and a
better more affordable selection to
people I mean come on this this sells
itself here every month every month
butcher buck ships a curated selection
of high-quality meat right to my home
all meat is free of antibiotics added
hormones each box has nine to eleven
pounds of meat enough for 24 individual
meals or during a pandemic 48 I can
customize my box or go with one of
theirs either way I get exactly what I
want put your box is a no-brainer
it's the best meat ship right to my door
which means one less trip to the
grocer's options like 100% grass-fed and
finish be
free-range organic chicken my favorite
heritage breed pork wild-caught alaskan
salmon and sugar nitrate-free bacon with
butcher box you get the highest quality
meat around for just six dollars a meal
and they even have free shipping
nationwide except Alaska in Hawaii but
they can fend for themselves right they
can go kill a bear or pick a pineapple
right now butcher bucks is offering new
members ground beef for life that's two
pounds of ground beef in every box for
the life of their subscription plus $20
off their first bucks just go to butcher
box.com slash bar or enter the promo
code Barbie URR at checkout
that's butcher bucks calm slash bar b
you are r or into the promo code bur at
check out all capitals anyways me I'm so
happy you came on I'm bummed out I knew
the day was coming I knew Tom Brady was
gonna retire or leave you knew at some
point it was going to happen and today
Brady Tom Brady is the quarterback I
know the New England Patriots the
greatest quarterback of all time
bunch ins husband oh yeah her last name
is bunch ins bündchen bunch and punching
punching punching punching yeah that's
part of being a supermodel you got to
have the you also have to have the new
unique name like Gisele Tyra Cindy
exactly Cyndi's theorem I so I thought
are you like done crying about it or
crying about it you know you're an
[ __ ] but such a I've been such an
adult about it you know what number is
he number what I know
all right then then what are you giving
me [ __ ] lower to number one
no he's number one he's number one no
he's never won no the number on his
jersey Oh is he gonna go someplace and
play the football some leave you on an
OD pause
[Music]
oh he's gonna go play a Florida let me
hold you while you recover from this
devastating awful time don't want I
don't want to play with us anymore I'm
gonna go someplace up and take my ball
called Florida oh you are so heartless
I'm gonna pay more money what's going on
well why would he leave well he never
did the free-agent thing in a number of
times he restructured his contract so
you know he sent money down the road so
we'd have money a you know now against
the salary cap we could sign better
players okay so he's been nothing but a
team player and I think he totally
deserved to shop himself around the
league to see where he could get the
most money there's no state tax you know
go down there they got some good wide
receivers it's a bit of a weird choice
but financially I get it he was cool
enough not to go to the doll fits I mean
what's the team that he's gonna be
playing with the Tampa Tampa Bay egg
rolls egg roll the egg rolls yes
Buccaneers yes I feel like that's not a
team you hear a lot about although that
might change now the bread has gone down
south but I didn't feel like that's not
that's not a team you hear a lot about
it's not like the New York Giants or the
oh my god if he got in the New York
Giants oh my god Boston people wow that
would have been tough you white guys
would be besides
[ __ ] red in the face screaming on CNN
I gotta tell you though that is a really
good-looking uniform okay other New York
Giants they have a great uniform we have
a terrible uniform mm-hmm I don't know
what our uniform is it's all red white
and blue
Patriots means silver and that's that
triangle guy yeah I I don't even
understand I don't even know what the
[ __ ] it is the flying Elvis whatever the
[ __ ] people call it I don't get it I
don't it's not I don't know what it is
it's a white guy from back it's like do
you know that movie alien yeah it's like
Pat Patriot was on a ship with that
thing and then they had a kid and then
that's what the [ __ ] it looked like wait
I have a question though so why wouldn't
he go to like what the [ __ ] did that
mean you know when he when you have that
line where you're like did you to make
this spoiler alert for anyone who hasn't
[ __ ] seen the first season now all
right we were talking about did you guys
make this okay yeah I'm pretty sensitive
today
all right go okay no it's not that
why no it's not that high-profile
franchise can I tell you it's you're
asking great sports questions oh well
yeah the only thing I can think is is
state tax but Nia it's not really that
he's left the Patriots okay cuz I mean
I've known that that was coming for
[ __ ] six years I'm like is this the
last year is this the last year was this
the last year so you kind of prepare for
that it it's what it is is when you're
of a certain age like me
51 gonna be 52 years old you're
constantly reminded of your mortality so
sports is a great escape and one of the
things that does remind you and this is
not a new thought they've written a
bunch of stuff about this but there is
that thing of like wait Tom Brady is
gonna you know is gonna be too old to
play football
whenever I don't know who knows with him
he might play another [ __ ] three
years and get three titles with Tampa
but like when somebody retires like you
know watching Larry Bird when he
his back and then he couldn't play
anymore watching Michael Jordan on the
Wizards when he was still [ __ ] great
but he wasn't as quick couldn't his jump
as high as everybody else it just
reminds you it was like that can happen
to that guy what the [ __ ] gonna happen
to me so there is a you know it's like
going I remember when I went to go see
one of my favorite bands from my
childhood they got back together and
when they first came out on stage I was
like oh my god is amazing I was like oh
[ __ ] they're old mm-hmm look how old
they are they gonna die I'm gonna die
everybody dies why didn't he retire he
has like millions and millions of
dollars he'll be able to get he'll be
able to be in commercials like left
right and center like it's not like he's
gonna be hurting for money but it's just
is it just the love of the game like
your fame of the Tampa I'm sorry Tampa
but like does he love football that much
that he's willing to move to Tampa come
on it's one of those things
Giselle's gonna move to Tampa you gonna
take that beautiful [ __ ] stallion and
put her in Tampa oh she must love him
listen not for nothing she did go to
Foxborough anyway fair enough right off
of Route one sweetheart okay you thought
the fashion shows in Paris blew your
mind where do you hit some of these
Chinese restaurants along Route one here
get yourself a poopoo platter crab
rangoon I got three words for you
Chinese food in Boston though people do
not understand anything better all they
do on all of these cloths all they do in
these [ __ ] food shows is trying to
decide who has the best [ __ ] pizza
and just sitting there Twp waiting to be
crushed for a high rated food [ __ ]
show is the best Chinese food it is in
Massachusetts absolutely oh the New
England area 100 is not it is 100% the
best and it is 0% authentic Chinese food
yeah this is our
I guess well now can you say a
chinese-americans version they looked at
us and they were like they don't like
this healthy [ __ ] they do not want to be
skinny a little let's give these pieces
and let's give these people what they
want and God bless them the Chinese
people that emigrated to New England
thank God a lot of thanks on this this
podcast god bless you
the the what you came up with it's just
I every time I go back I got a couple of
joints there's a heavy Chinese
population in San Francisco I would
guess that that's more authentic
probably yeah no no come on like nobody
does it
crab rangoon the poopoo platter the [ __ ]
chicken fingers what the [ __ ] are those
you can't get those anywhere other than
in New England chicken fingers chickens
don't have fingers they do anyway haha
right yes they do
get chicken fingers like everywhere no
you can't yeah you can no you can't
chicken oh well maybe they call em
chicken tenders they don't do these
things alike is long is like a Fievel
whiffle finger longer than that like
Bill Russell's levels long fingers well
we'll miss you Tommy Boy go out there
and throw the ball over and tap I can
lessen that was a little bit of JFK in
there go over there and throw the ball
kid then you throwing the kid dude kid
so what else what else you got going on
in this podcast well I have a bone to
pick with you I know that's why you said
you wanted to do the park yes all right
here we go everybody else no I
earlier today I was you know just
expressing my foot how do I [ __ ] up
already it's not even noon what is the
problem can I can i express myself or
once again are you gonna shut me down
for having an opinion and that's the
point that I'm trying to bring up your
stuff see where you stop please what do
you mean victim
you you're not a victim can i press
myself can I not be shut down I was
sitting there complaining about
something else in headset and you were
like mad mad mad at mad we know what you
said was just a lot of you just open
your mouth and I came out it's like I
can't even like just express myself in
my own home without you trying to shout
me down and shut me up it's like the our
our life isn't your [ __ ] podcast
where you just have the solo mic and you
just go on and on and no one's there to
refute you or we're like people have
opinions and now you know and they're
allowed to express them and you cuz it's
funny when someone's reading you the
riot act and then in the middle they
mispronounce a word it just kills all
your steam and then you see in the
person's face like did they notice that
do I still have the momentum and then
you try to get it going again
it's like I'm allowed to complain about
things you like you know we just got to
do what we got to do and all these like
stupid [ __ ] platitudes it's like
allow me to make my point I am so sick
what are you sick of today bill of
people telling me the dumb thing Trump
said I get it you don't like the guy I
don't like the guy this is a time for
everybody to pull in the same direction
and shut the [ __ ] up and just stop with
the did you believe what he did I have
all of these friends you a question why
are you allowed to express yourself and
I can't express myself you express
yourself and you're sitting there going
like I will really make money it is
pressing yourself and then you want to
sit here and act like you're in some
kind of situation where you can't
express yourself jealousy you're [ __ ]
bald head they having some ready they
have open mic Nia's if you want to go
down just do an open mic you can talk to
you about it apparently I can't though
unless it's you sitting up in the room
guys can see how much you can't express
yourself in this relationship and all of
a sudden you will go into like a
five-minute monologue about God knows
what about anything at any time
so I can't talk about like something
that annoyed me that I saw without you
being like I am so sick of people doing
this or that it's like how [ __ ] dare
you who are you you're so sick of people
talking about things go [ __ ] yourself
this is our relationship everybody loved
at the time of Corona and then just
notice how much she just talked how much
I could even get a word in and how she
acts like she's like kept in a [ __ ]
tower waiting for some prince to rescue
her Mia you [ __ ] Gogi flick believe
with food and you know and you dump it
in on me I'm not dumping it on you I'm
just expressing and like I mean you're
just expressing but when I come in and I
express myself it's a five-minute tyree
it is oh really
that was like two or three sentences and
you went to a whole thing about like how
you're tired of people talking about the
dumb things that he says like you're not
the talking police yeah I don't want to
hear it you you've told me to certain
subjects I'm not allowed to talk about
anymore so I stop I don't want to hear
any I get it he's a [ __ ] I don't know
he's disturbing the man is disturbing I
don't know what his [ __ ] problem is I
feel bad for people in his cabinet who
have to sit across from like I'm working
for this [ __ ] guy I feel bad for him
alright but if the [ __ ] tells me
to stay inside I'm [ __ ] staying
inside no but my point was he wasn't
saying that before he was saying that it
was a hoax and all this other that's how
he deals stretch by lying to the
American everything is a hoax and now
he's changing his too and he's like oh
we've been telling him to stay inside
this whole time it's like no you weren't
no you weren't and I don't you I was a
soccer team that's all was I wanted to
get it out and vent it out and I would
think that you have
loving partner for the last 16 years
were allowed me the space to speak about
the things that I feel strongly about
all right well here's my thing you think
you can track this guy buddy
you can trash this guy all you want but
I never heard it when somebody wears a
blue tie and they're doing the exact
same [ __ ] thing and and that's the
[ __ ] problem
which drives me nuts about news junkies
and people who are into politics
it's Hatfields and McCoys and it's just
like when are you gonna [ __ ] stand
back and see that these guys make 500
grand a [ __ ] year the president okay
he makes 500 grand a year because we're
not gonna give you all the millions at
first what we're gonna do is you make
sure you dot all the eyes and scratch
you know cross all the t's and then in
the end then you come back and then you
give us a [ __ ] speech and we'll
grossly overpaid um ass [ __ ] speech
that we're not even listening to and
that's us washing our bribe money and
they all at the end of their [ __ ]
goddamn administrations every [ __ ]
one of them goes out and speaks to the
same group of [ __ ] rich people all
right so spare me and you know yeah I'm
[ __ ] the man of the house here I got
you okay and I got my daughter and I'm
trying to [ __ ] stay put and a
positive thing I don't need any more of
the [ __ ] oh so that's what it's about
you're trying to just not I'm trying to
just [ __ ] chill I'm on the podcast
trying to get people to chill and I
don't need two people
did you see how the skies falling today
all right well then you should say that
then you shouldn't make it like like
you're so tired of people you should be
like listen I'm just trying to protect
my mental energy in space and not have
it you know I would love to do this to
you when you [ __ ] fly off the handle
and then you tell me why because of
something from your childhood and I'd be
like well then what you should have said
was when I was eight someone took an ice
cream cone and put it on my fanny and
ever since then I've had this rare issue
about desserts
wait did you tell me that I some years
ago like well many so we put an ice
cream on your fanny
on my head this boy yes this boy
and you're such an ass how old were you
I forget how old up maybe 10 or
something like that but I was hanging
out with my friends Jade and what did
you say apartment complex and this boy
and this other boy I don't know he was
probably being annoying and I probably
wasn't like I don't even remember what
happened oh that's convenient he took he
took an ice-cream he put it wait did he
put it on my head or something and then
he hit me in the stomach well that's how
boys say they like you at 10:00 yeah
that's and I also think you probably
said something having been with you for
16 years [ __ ] child and that was a
bully
okay he was also a child what are you in
a try them as an adult why are you
sticking up for him why are you sticking
up for me I kind of like them it's baby
Nene whenever you have your stories
about baby baby I'm always like oh this
happened oh that's so I'm just imagining
you as a little boy and I just want to
hug you like I know but you do that
while you're looking at the phone on
Instagram Oh terrible swiping swipe
I can it Nia I'm the jerk and you're the
hero pretty much all right I got taenia
this was an outstanding visit are you
kicking me out no but why me no I do
like a half hour I mean you [ __ ]
don't know [ __ ] about sports and you
crush the Tom Brady [ __ ] you trashed me
thank you I'm telling you this like
sports fans could not trash me better
than you trash me I actually at one
point stopped laughing because I was
admiring it like how you just you're
[ __ ] funny man you really [ __ ]
funny you're funnier than a lot of
comedians I know you really are
alright having said that though I'm glad
that you know why because that kid put
an ice cream on your head he hit you in
the stomach
that's a stand-up comic childhood
[ __ ] story yeah no I've had but see
that was an instance where I wasn't able
to use my cleverness to get me out of a
situation I think you tried to use your
cleverness and he wasn't avenue yeah and
he didn't know what to do with that but
then later on down the line
I had potential another potential bully
situation I was able to flip the script
and then the bully became you stole the
line you stole the line stole a line and
I used it from Sanford inside red fox
red fox and I used it what was the line
it was I'm gonna stick her face and so I
could stop your faces some dough and
make guerrilla cookies yeah that was the
line he said on Sanford & Son
when he was it was his um his
sister-in-law what was the contest name
yes so anyway and Sanford you all
everybody was like oh and then they went
back and they told her and then she kind
of confronted me on the playground but I
just kind of like blew it off and then
she told on me she told the teacher and
the teacher was like you better not be
spreading rumors and talking about my
kids and I was like whatever and then
she became like my protector and like
took me under her wing I was like her
little sister and like no one ever is
this your childhood is just that movie
my bodyguard this is my childhood what
is my bodyguard I was you know the only
kids meatballs I was getting picked on
by a young Matt Dillon and then the dude
from later was in Full Metal Jacket he
came along a man-child in high school
and they became friends and he needed a
part for his motorcycle and then they
finally found it and then you know he
kept Matt Dillon away from him and then
then Matt Dillon's like alright I can
get another big friend and then other
things happen Wow
anyway I love that he doubled down after
he put the ice cream on your head he
then also hit you in the stomach I mean
that was he gave me a two-piece gave you
a two piece in here and I loved it it
was really nice I was really upset did
you cry of course I did I was on your
face it mixed with your tears no I like
that
- sir never cried and I told my dad then
but he was gone I don't even know where
he came from who he was the abandoned
child I made up why don't you do it an
open-mic near you got you have a nose in
this story I can't imagine doing what
you do though I can't imagine doing what
you do
I can't imagine putting an ice cream on
your head and then slapping you in the
stomach
I might have to recreate this punch me
in the stomach I love this kid Wow
well everybody's the same height at 10
come on it was the smallest people of my
what are you talking about Mia yes I was
I was a small kid I was not a big kid by
any means yeah you had that big mouth so
didn't you well she's running that Yap
there might be that yeah but I was not a
physically intimidating person he thinks
[ __ ] like that didn't happen to me when
I was a kid well why don't you talk
about it why don't you tell right what
time I was on an altar boy retreat
mm-hmm we went to Rocky Point it was an
old it was an old the [ __ ] was it a
amusement park mm-hmm so they've gone
only all these rides for free or
whatever and then we got on like the
ride well you know that takes you up
over the park so sitting you know it was
me and two other altar boys and you know
I was making him laugh and everything so
we were going up and then you know and
then it comes around so you see the
people returning so they were passing us
and there was these two kids and they
said something bla bla bla and I went
through through one of them and he turns
around he goes and then I was just like
oh [ __ ] right so then it came around and
now we [ __ ] start coming back to
where we got on and I'm seeing him he's
down there pacing like a [ __ ] lion
he's got like four friends with them the
two people I'm with I just like dude
what the [ __ ] did you get us into
and we're sliding down like Quint into
the the mouth of the [ __ ] shark and I
don't know why I don't know where my
friends went but I got off and next
thing you know I was in this circle and
they were pushing me and every time I
would regain my balance another kid
would push me I remember he had a dead
tooth he was like a [ __ ] kid from the
Depression era so you know he [ __ ]
swung on me I covered up and they just
stomp me or whatever and then I got up
he how that's my wait wait wait wait and
then I got up and they was like yeah you
[ __ ] [ __ ] whatever and I was just
like oh and then I still it'd be you you
only talk because you have all your
friends and I was like why did I say
that mm-hmm and then they've just so
then they just was just two of them and
then they just followed me around the
park so I stood in the next line I tried
to get to you know to try to get my [ __ ]
together uh-huh I stood in the next line
it was the [ __ ] bumper cars which is
not a good ride to get on after you just
got the [ __ ] kicked out of you so then
they came back up he said now my by
myself fight me again and I pussied out
and I didn't do it and I felt really bad
about myself and but then what was great
was this Asian dude got on the bumper
cars and he was like in his teeny he's
like a teenager or something and he just
had no idea how to [ __ ] it was the
stereotype and he was just flooring it
and he was just slamming into the walls
I do when I tell you this guy was
killing the entire line we were crying
laughing and he was laughing too and
then he have it in reverse and he would
back up when he slamming the other one
he was just killing himself but he was
having the best time and he saw us
laughing and he was laughs we will all
just [ __ ] crying laughing and oh man
so many things happen that day one of my
buddies who's now no longer around
unfortunately I remember there was this
little kid and you know that game this
is what what [ __ ] we were I mean I
wasn't like this but like my friends
they just like the key member that game
you put the quarters in and then like
the claw arm would come and try to get
like my kid prizes so it was all a bunch
of [ __ ] prizes and then like one grand
prize yeah and it was this little kid
all right a little black kid he was
playing right and he [ __ ] goes he
finally gets the camera and for whatever
reason he hits my friend he goes oh man
check it out I got the camera right and
as it was coming up he's only like 9
years old as it was coming up
but he went over he just slam the
controls oh so then the kid starts
chasing my buddy around and he's
laughing just running in a circle then
his older brother showed up who thank
God was totally cool was like I'm not
gonna stomp this little white boy and
he's kind of like you know what but I
was just like yeah we were that was a
hell of a day that was a hell of a day
there was a lot well this is the end of
the podcast Nia this is like going on to
LA why I usually just to a half hour I
got in 54 minutes gave them an extra 24
minutes because I know that they're on
house arrest you're welcome hey how
about a round of applause for Nia Rene
Hill crushing it on the podcast here
folks
oh then the false humility to end it I
mean it was [ __ ] it's just a perfect
a perfect appearance and that you know
and I think that's a very fitting for
Tom Brady you know what I mean
he played quarterback perfectly for the
New England Patriots and then you came
on and had a Tom Brady esque
appearance having said that I'm gonna
see if I can go down to the supermarket
with my [ __ ] proper mask here get
some ice cream put it on a cone stick it
on your head and slap you right in your
stomach all right love you sweetheart
get the [ __ ] out of here all right
everybody thank you so much for
listening to the podcast enjoy the music
picked out by the always wonderful and
Ruth emili´s and then we have a bonus
half-hour of a Greatest Hits Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
morning podcasts have a great weekend
stay positive do what the [ __ ] they say
don't watch 24 hour news they're gonna
solve it it's gonna be fine this time
next year we're all gonna be laughing at
it right okay hey what's going on it's
Bill Byrne it's the Monday morning
podcast from Monday March 19 2012
[ __ ] cold out here in Los Angeles if
you're wondering about the weather
report yesterday
Cole does not bug me unless I'm in Los
Angeles then it bugs me
you know from in Cleveland if I'm in
Boston if I'm in New York if I'm in
Philly I don't give a [ __ ] if it's cold
I'll put on a pocket right but when I'm
out here in LA it really bothers me is
just something annoying about being cold
while looking at a palm tree just
[ __ ] bugs the [ __ ] out of me it
doesn't make any sense you know it's
like seeing a skinny Santa Claus it's
like what are you doing I thought you're
supposed to be a tub of [ __ ] how can you
be jolly if you're in shape if you ever
met a jolly skinny person you know this
suck there's a certain level of being
fat where you just find you just I don't
know I don't know if you just psyched
because you're eating cookies and you
know give a [ __ ] but you can still tie
your shoes like that's that level of fat
you want to be at where you're eating
pizza and you're eating cookies and yeah
you're fat but you know you put on a
sweater and you go oh oh yeah you got
rosy cheeks and nobody cares nobody's
looking at you nobody's judging you but
then when you go beyond it when you go
beyond it is when your stomach comes out
from underneath that sweater and
everybody can see it you know but you
can't see it right because you're so fat
and even when the wind blows you don't
notice it because you're all warm with
all that blubber you know there's that
there's that there's a [ __ ] I don't
know there's this there's a sweet spot
being fat where it where no one's making
funny of being fat and you're eating all
[ __ ] food but nobody's trashing you so I
guess it's out that's what makes you
jolly you know oh I get to eat all this
[ __ ] food and nobody's judging me then
once you go beyond it then you start
[ __ ] crying you know I'm one of those
reality shows I don't know what I'm
talking about
I don't want to be doing this podcast
right now I'm not even lying I'm gonna
lie to you I came spit it out a [ __ ]
exhaust if I got a bunch of [ __ ] to do
tomorrow which is today by the time
you're listening to it you know I really
don't feel like doing this [ __ ] so it's
gonna be quick I'm getting right to the
[ __ ] point
all right I already solved why certain
levels of fat people at jolly you know
right there if you guys weren't so
selfish that could take up your whole
[ __ ] week you know but not you guys
like I'm blaming you guys for this thing
that I started I just realized I haven't
even looked at any half of this [ __ ]
crap here so what happened this week
bill what'd you do this week Willy
I um I didn't do any [ __ ] stand I
think I maybe I did stand up this week
I'm on vacation people I'm still on
vacation
still on vacations you guys sit there
and you work putting in an honest day
work making somebody else's dream come
true and that dream evidently was to
stick everybody in these little [ __ ]
cubicles everything what a fire hazard a
cubicle is what if there's a fire in
your little doorway you know there's no
other way to get out what are you gonna
do shouldn't it be another doorway to
and to the cubicle next to you do you
have a little ladder on the front of it
we climb up and over your terminal why
are you still sitting in that [ __ ]
thing surrounded by plastic they can't
give you anything how about like can
they make your mouse made out of like
wood or maybe some sort of precious
metal to somehow act like they give a
[ __ ] about you on any level do you know
I have a I live in this old house now
this old house is [ __ ] old this old
house has old wire in this old house and
Billy's got to pay for it
and I got a big fat truck and every time
I back it in I start saying god damn and
[ __ ] I can't [ __ ] get it in the
garage so you know what I did the other
day I said hey hey who knows how to make
garage doors wider and I found somebody
I found somebody on make my garage doors
wider calm and the person came over and
they
my garage doors wider and I backed my
[ __ ] truck in there you know [ __ ]
like butter so you guys don't have to
listen to me [ __ ] about that against an
opposite and they go on this is [ __ ]
great you know I can put my truck in
there I don't have to worry about it you
know and there's no problems so what do
I do
I [ __ ] jump in the Prius the other
day you know the yin and the yang I got
the gas guzzler and I got the hoe my god
it's like a tree kind of car so I'm
gonna go down and watch some final four
[ __ ] action or whatever March Madness
whatever you call it and you know as you
guys know I'm not a big fan of
basketball I love the first 97% of it
it's that last 3% with the 58 timeouts
and the fouls and the commercials you
know I watched the game today it was one
of the worst sporting experiences I've
ever had
I watched st. Louis the st. Louis
fairies or something like that there was
some sort of the gremlins versus the the
Michigan State but okay 20-minute first
half 20 minutes second half okay the
first I don't know 38 minutes of the
game are not even 37 minutes of the game
I don't know it seemed like it took 90
minutes to play it's flying and I'm like
this is why I love college basketball as
opposed to the excruciating 48 minutes
of NBA hoop and then what happens the
final [ __ ] three minutes I swear to
god it took 50 minutes to play Jesus
Christ they're up by 7 it's over wow
that took point eight seconds off the
clock goes to the line for a one at one
[ __ ] and guy misses the ball he
throws it down [ __ ] files another guy
right time [ __ ] I had my shoes on
I'm trying to leave cuz I got to get my
buddy a ride cuz I got [ __ ] to do but we
want to see the end of the [ __ ] game
and I swear to God the final 45 seconds
it took like six minutes to play 45
second
and I know every once in a while
somebody can hit that big shot and
everybody goes oh [ __ ] in a Buffalo Wild
Wings right and then your [ __ ]
waitress comes over with a ref shirt
tied off you know just under the titties
cleavage showing
hey guys how are ya you want some more
wings did we win
yay stick the legal tender in my orifice
please
right I know every once in a while you
have one of those things right but you
know what 99% of the time in basketball
that doesn't happen and you're just
sitting there letting six months six
minutes see a life go by to watch 45
seconds of action you know I don't know
so anyway so I go to buddy's my house
buddy's house a buddy of Mines house
there we go was actually an apartment
why do you have to exaggerate Bill you
know why are you trying to enhance your
life and I go [ __ ] yourself all right so
I Drive over to his apartment right and
he lives in this part of the city where
there's no [ __ ] parking and I'm
really trying not to lose my [ __ ] I'm
trying to control my temper cuz I don't
want to be this guy I really don't I'd
like to be that I'd like to be jolly I
like to eat some pizzas some cookies now
my stomach hanging out underneath my
sweater nobody gives me [ __ ] about it
right oh so whatever so I get my [ __ ]
Prius and I Drive down the road I can't
find the parking so I say [ __ ] it you
know I'm gonna Park it a meter so I park
at the meter and I reach into my little
[ __ ] console to get out my little
Bhagya quarters and I forgot they're not
there cuz that [ __ ] broke my [ __ ]
window in my driveway broke the window
on my [ __ ] car and stole the bag of
quarters we say go douche douche right
and then I have to pay for the [ __ ]
window so I pull up to the meter and I
don't have a goddamn any quarters I
don't have any quarters
so I evidently I have to use my credit
card something I don't like doing I
don't like using my credit card on you
know in a parking meter on a parking
meter I don't like
doing that cuz there's a record that I
was there okay now I stick that thing in
and that takes a lot of stuff off the
table for me okay I can't like get into
a fight with somebody and he pulls a
knife we wrestle for it he falls on it
and dies but I have no connection to him
and you know and I can't just [ __ ]
leave without getting caught right I
can't call somebody a [ __ ]
I mean I can do all that stuff but
there's that the paper trail he was
there no I wasn't yes you were we got
your credit card well I didn't call her
a [ __ ]
well why'd you lie about being there all
right listen I might be in charge with
anything cuz if I am I want a lawyer if
not I'm [ __ ] leaving alright remember
that first 48 that's what you say so
anyways so I gotta use the [ __ ]
credit card so I use a credit card all
right all I can get it's two hours of
time there's an hour and something on
the meter so I'm trying to pay for
twenty minutes it's all [ __ ]
confusing I gave them two hours of time
for twenty minutes so I go on I walk in
this guy's [ __ ] apartment i watch the
goddamn game right I'm thinking two
hours is gonna be enough time out time
out file file file time out all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] right by the time I
figure out what's going on it's three
and a half hours later oh my god Jesus
Christ you're an idiot bill you forgot
you've parked at a [ __ ] meter you're
gonna have a ticket right and I come
walk it down the street
and I'm walking up to my car what do I
see the [ __ ] meter maid who's a guy
pulls up I still call him meter maids
even if it's a guy you know what kind of
a [ __ ] man does that job and I give a
[ __ ] if it is a recession
go break into somebody's Prius and be a
man about it right
I see the [ __ ] meter maid man pulls
up right as I'm there and I'm laughing
my ass off going you gotta be [ __ ]
kidding me I got away with it and I jump
in my Prius and I Drive away Wow
laughing my ass off call up my buddy I
wouldn't believe it I got there right
he's the [ __ ] blah blah blah yeah you
had to be there right I'm out thinking
it's the [ __ ] greatest story ever all
right put my car in the [ __ ] driveway
I don't know what I did after that came
inside had a couple of whiskey's and I
yelled at every
in the house that I love you know
typical evening for me so the next
morning I wake up and I looked at the
side of my car and evidently somebody
had hit my [ __ ] car
I'm driving away last night you know I'm
driving away thinking oh look at me I
got away from the [ __ ] meter matey
and somebody caved in the entire side of
my [ __ ] car you know I don't know
what it is about my Prius it's just
[ __ ] every [ __ ] three days
somebody smashed us into it I just can't
keep the deadside you know I'm not one
of these douchebags who gets a [ __ ]
car and went them something breaks she
just say [ __ ] it and you leave it that
way and next thing you know you look
like Lamont driving over to Fred
Sanford's house I'm not going out like
that even if it is a Prius I'm keeping
it nice alright I get the [ __ ] thing
detailed I don't give a [ __ ] I get the
[ __ ] interior shampooed I keep it
nice that riving around some you know
it's already bad enough I'm drying
around on something that it has bicycle
tires on top of that I'm have [ __ ]
density alright I got an image here
people I'm trying to keep up Christ I'm
so [ __ ] tired right now I don't wanna
do this guy didn't play him with the
[ __ ] up talk what am I talking about
that's how you guys I saw Sandra
Bernhard this weekend I didn't do what
he stand up I went down and Whitney and
her mom went down and we saw Santa
Bernard down at the La Jolla Playhouse
or something like that and she's [ __ ]
awesome god damn rock star you know it's
kind of a cabaret thing where she would
sing songs and that type of stuff you
know and I think I was the only straight
guy there under the age of 45 but I
loved it I actually wish that she would
do more standup
she was [ __ ] hilarious and she was
just I don't know that perfect kind of
just not given a [ __ ] just an absolute
beast I've always been a huge fan of
hers and so if you get a chance to see
her I definitely [ __ ] recommend it
the [ __ ] was she gonna she went off on
she did like [ __ ] 10 minutes on
Gwyneth Paltrow just trashing her it's
phenomenal and all her [ __ ] about you
know watching TV you make it fun of
Cindy Crawford stupid Cindy serum all
that
[ __ ] phenomenal night I actually got to
sit and watch somebody else do stand-up
for once you know stood in line bought a
DVD for Nia right and then stick out my
anima community - right did that took a
picture you know I had a little fanboy
night it's nice that some [ __ ] has to
cave in the side of my [ __ ] car oh
Jesus what the hell am I talking about
any what I'm talking about anymore you
know you know what I think it's time for
people I think it's time for a [ __ ]
commercial new this week blow pops
remember those things that the ice-cream
man used to sell those red white and
blue rockets teaches the girls how to
suck dick nice right well they're on
sale people they're on sale this week if
they're an ice-cream truck comes by you
just mention this podcast and you just
yell out and they'll give you ten
percent off a blow pop all right what
the [ __ ] am I talking sorry I don't have
the kind of the cop in front of me what
the hell is it the [ __ ] is wrong with me
why wouldn't I have any of this out
there it is the advertising schedule
here what do we got stamps calm again do
I really need to go through this again
stamps calm everybody you know you know
the deal how would you like to have the
post office in your own apartment relax
I don't mean literally stamps.com
everybody have you ever been sitting
around rubbing your balls at 1:00 in the
morning going god I wish I could put a
stamp on a letter well with stamps calm
that dream is now a reality okay so why
don't you call Oprah and start crying
about it because your dreams have come
true all right
look no one wants to go down to the post
office it's a dangerous place to go okay
every six weeks somebody's down there
doing something crazy right there's
always some homeless guy you know
holding the door for you as you walk in
and then expects you know that you're
gonna pay him on the way out like that's
how life is like that's how quickly you
get a return and
spent you know like I couldn't open that
door myself you filthy son of a [ __ ]
why do you want to deal with that forget
about when you go in there and there's
some old lady trying to male or dentures
to Cincinnati you don't stand behind
that how do I weigh it
it'll be nice if you had a scale in your
own apartment a house a dwelling or even
your cubicle all you got to do peoples
go to stamps calm you can buy and print
official US postage on your own computer
and you can print out those stamps
everybody what you think you were just
gonna stare at him on the screen they
got it all figured out
alright stamps calm we'll also give you
a digital scale to weigh your packages
you type in the zip code it's very easy
up and spend it all my DVDs it's it's
amazing it is amazing right now stamps
calm is a special offer from my
listeners all 17 of them used my last
name Burpee you are are all capital
letters you get a no risk trial plus
$110 bonus offer that includes a digital
scale and $55 and free postage okay I
don't know what else you need go to
stamps calm before you do anything else
click on the microphone the radio make a
phone at the top of the homepage you
type in burr that stamps calm everybody
enter birth how is that was that a nice
read I think it was I think there was
just enough comedy in there while I got
the information out to Jesus so anyways
I live in this old-ass house alright and
whoever lived here before I don't think
the people right before the people for
them before them this is a great old
house and the great thing about having
an old house is they have these old
fixtures door handles hinges other
handles you know wood carvings all that
type of stuff that makes the thing
unique you know what the worst is is
when somebody lives in the house before
you and they don't [ __ ] appreciate it
and what they do is they take all those
wonderful features they take them out
they go down to Home Depot and they buy
some plastic hunk of [ __ ] they use that
as a goddamn door handle well you know
what
am I really gonna talk about brass door
handles at this point is that how far
the [ __ ] podcast has come I got a
[ __ ] door handle it's made out of
brass and it has 90 years of schmutz on
it okay Fatty Arbuckle banged a [ __ ] up
against it probably sometime in the
early 30s and that schmutz from that
[ __ ] [ __ ] is still on the door handle
okay and I went out and bought myself a
little [ __ ] kit and I'm trying to
polish that thing today and I realized
how annoying it must have been to work
for rich people back in the day we had
to polish up their candelabras and their
[ __ ] spoons and at teacups oh my god
I would [ __ ] rub my balls on all
their [ __ ] Forks and everything
before I put them in the drawer and
there's no way these people didn't do
that there is nothing more annoying and
I know these people back in the day had
no idea what an iPad was you know they
had no idea what it'd be like to have
live streaming porn on some little
[ __ ] plastic box right on that table
where they could rub one out whenever
they wanted to I realized it was a
simple time you know back in the day
like an apple was a dessert at least
according to my research it was I mean I
back in the day you watched those Tom
Sawyer movies and he'd be a whitewash my
fence and I'll give you an apple oh boy
a [ __ ] Apple
okay couldn't believe it I don't
understand you figured then there was a
whole bunch of apple trees all around
once you go climb one up you dumb [ __ ]
you wouldn't have to paint the fence
do you really thought about it but then
again he was an orphan wasn't Tom Sawyer
and orphaned was the Huck Finn I don't
[ __ ] know what am I talking about
anyways to be back in the day just had
to sit there and shine up all these
[ __ ] rich people's [ __ ] you know
I bought this you that you can't afford
make it even shinier and you got to sit
there doing that you know the same
motion over and over again the [ __ ]
your knuckles swelling up right just
sitting there you know I always want to
always want to drive a stagecoach and
that dream just never happened for you
and there you are your whole [ __ ]
life you got to sit there and shine
spoons
not wash them you gotta wash him and
then he got a [ __ ] shine him up let
me tell you something I [ __ ] with this
brass door handle for about 20 minutes
and I was like you know what [ __ ] this
no I didn't I went on YouTube but I
actually looked up how to shine a brass
[ __ ] door so now I'm going down to
the [ __ ] hardware store and tomorrow
and I'm gonna get some [ __ ] low-grade
ore high-grade [ __ ] SOS pad and I'm
gonna do that with a little toothbrush
tomorrow shine this son of a [ __ ] up
and somehow I feel like it's gonna fill
the void good can you guys fill me
slowly going crazy um well if you can't
I don't give a [ __ ]
eight you can be been wondering you know
I've realised that forever I haven't
even told you guys how to email me its
bill at the mm podcast.com alright bill
at that's the the a with the circle
around it like Walt Disney drew it right
bill at the mm podcast.com okay I said
it three times if you can't figure it
out go [ __ ] yourself I ain't trying to
say go [ __ ] yourself because if you're
trying to email me to tell me I gave you
the wrong email I'm not going to get it
you can either go there or go or go or
go to billboard.com slash contact and
contact is spelt the American Way co n
ta CT okay not the Hungarian way is that
a [ __ ] moth you goddamn [ __ ] I need
a [ __ ] buy an old house it has
such character hang on a second I'm
gonna kill that [ __ ] thing and risk
losing all my pita listeners hang on
alright I'm back one less moth in the
house trying to eat my [ __ ] sweat the
mothballs work or that's like ice cubes
in the drink of moths because I swear to
God I got I got moth balls all over the
[ __ ] place and he's got its I think
they're throwing him in a highball glass
as they [ __ ] shout out my turtlenecks
I dress like dick cavett now did I tell
you guys that anyways the contact lint
at the top of billboard.com is bill at
the mm podcast calm or billboard.com
slash contact send me an email you know
let me know you listening do it don't do
it
it gives a [ __ ] do you even give a [ __ ]
at this point I think a lot of my
listeners right now are just sitting
with their hands their head on their
hand just staring off into space then I
got to be honest with you that's exactly
how I feel
I just don't have time to do this
tomorrow morning so I'm doing it right
now you know I mean it's kind of like
when you're building a toy for your kid
you don't really want to do it you know
you just plowing through it you're not
even thinking about the joy he's gonna
have you're just trying to get to step 8
where you can just finish this whole
[ __ ] thing you know last week I
brought up the different types of [ __ ]
blocks last week I brought up the
announcer that guy who can [ __ ] block
you from across the room second he sees
something you know happenin bidet all
right that guy you know then you guys
slowly slide your hand back down a thigh
back from up from underneath address you
know you just you have a good time
so he's another type of [ __ ] block
evidently this person named the
double-oh-seven s this is the friend of
the girl you're trying to hook up with
or who acts like she's indifferent and
acts like she's indifferent about
heading back to your or what this the
friend of the girl you're trying to hook
up with who acts like she's indifferent
about heading back to your place or
staying at the party but is secretly
texting 1,000 reasons to her friend as
to why they should get the [ __ ] out of
there that's the worst that's right why
don't you just man up and say I don't
want to bang you I'm leaving
so anyways just cuz she's not getting
any attention
she's always got some stupid
passive-aggressive look on her face as
she's texting and going on about why
they got to get to Mickey's cuz
everyone's there my keys cuz everyone's
there
yes always you know is there anything
worse than you know what something witty
things worse the guy your buddy
cock-blocking you or the ugly friend of
the hot girl you know you know what I
wish I did back in the day because I
always tried to ignore that person and
just keep working on the other girl even
though I wanted to tell the the [ __ ]
ugly one to go [ __ ] herself it's always
killed me that I never did because it
never worked out once that girls like
that one like I just wish just one time
I just said I'm sorry
right I might as well have done that
because once that [ __ ] goddamn I
don't know what something big and hairy
abominable snowman
Bigfoot I don't know what if I was
[ __ ] nut so sleepy I would had
something funny there you know what she
starts [ __ ] yelling the Marissa girls
not gonna bang you you know I mean she's
not gonna bang well maybe you should
just lean into Marissa and just be like
hey let me ask you a question why do you
hang out with such ugly women you know
what's your deal what do you insecure or
something I can't say what are you
insecure you got to keep it about the
other one do you have any good-looking
friends just something just something so
you can go down swing it I have no idea
why am i excited about the baseball
season start I haven't watched baseball
since David Ortiz flunked some tests and
I suppose like you know what [ __ ] this
for some reason I'm excited about
baseball I don't know why that is well
bill we don't know either can you figure
it out can you say something funny about
it are you just gonna just leave it out
there all right this guy wants money
advice Jesus Christ there's no way I'm
making an hour this is 27 minutes in and
I'm flailing absolutely flailing
which rocky was that one was that that
was the one where Apollo Creed got
[ __ ] killed by the Russian I must
break you
right those cheating bastards um Money
Advice bill I'm an OT our truck driver
what the [ __ ] is that off-track betting
what is that OT I don't know what that
is
alright I'll take your word for it I'm
an OT yard truck driver and have a
problem with blowing [ __ ] money like
a politician I have a wonderful fiance
with the great head on his shoulders and
she is great with money every time I see
the bank statements the balance is more
and more so I know she's doing a bang-up
job with our finances well let me tell
you something sir you are one perceptive
son of a [ __ ] you've seen another
bigger and I know that that must be a
good thing so what's the [ __ ] problem
you say well like I said I'm terrible
with money so I got one of them I got
one of them prepaid debit cards he
literally wrote one of them I like this
guy talks like Elvis and every Tuesday
payday my girl puts $50 on there so I
can get groceries that way I don't turn
into one of these fat shits that eats
every meal out out of the Wendy's out of
the Wendy's oh god this guy's great
hey eastbound and down loaded up and
truckin we're gonna do what they say
can't be done we're gonna get some
hookers at the next truck stop we ain't
gonna wear condoms and shoot some drugs
and we all get [ __ ] AIDS and pass it
all around
well $50 it's good for one week of
groceries but it's like pulling [ __ ]
teeth for extra money like save for
drinks or some rubbers now like for
drinks or some extracurriculars am I an
[ __ ] for thinking I deserve a few
extra bucks or what the [ __ ] bill by the
way [ __ ] has a sexy [ __ ] voice and
go [ __ ] yourself
are you an [ __ ] for thinking you
deserve a few extra bucks absolutely the
fact that that poor woman is legally
bound to you and you you have no concept
of how to hold on to money that would be
like I mean you're a guy like you're
supposed to [ __ ] earn a living to
support a family right if you have no
concept of that that would be like if
she had no concept of like how to have a
baby or how to blow somebody you know
what I mean
cuz that's what their job is sucking
dick and making patience Oh God
imagine my end of the balls to run for
president after doing this podcast for
five years how easy would it be to take
me down dude why don't you learn about
money do you really just want to float
around like with your [ __ ] eyes wide
open just not getting it don't you want
to understand money she's giving you 50
bucks a week you know why cuz you're too
[ __ ] stupid it gets 60 and I'm sure
you can crawl under a truck and modify
it I'm not saying you straight across
the board dumb but to not not to
understand money
it's I swear to god dude is one of the
dumbest things you honestly this is for
everybody it's one of the dumbest things
you could ever do in life is I
understand not understanding money up to
about 1819 but once you're to the point
where you can go to a library we can go
on the internet and you can just just
read up on it okay if you don't
understand money you're gonna be a
behind the 8-ball for your entire
[ __ ] life and you're basically gonna
be an indentured servant to credit card
companies and banks and your life is
gonna suck way more than it needs to
okay I'm not saying that just because
you understand money one of your kidneys
isn't gonna [ __ ] the bed bad shits
already gonna happen you don't need to
compound it with not understanding money
all right
this woman is the best thing that ever
[ __ ] happened to you
you don't understand money and you want
for drinks and some extracurriculars
what does that mean an Eightball if you
start with drinks and then you say I
like how safe for drinks or some
extracurriculars like boozing to you
isn't even an extracurricular activity
that's just you know let's like
nourishment whew so I'm assuming that
extracurriculars is at least a bag of
weed or maybe some condoms to bang some
trucker [ __ ] truck stop [ __ ] you know
listen sir you got a great [ __ ] woman
but she's only gonna put up with you not
understanding money for so long cuz it
someday point she's gonna want a goddamn
man okay especially once you have a
couple of kids
she doesn't need you being some adult
kids so I would say read up on money and
you'd understand what a favor she's
doing for you if your bank balance is
going up you're doing better than 90% of
the people out there alright so here's a
good thing you got a [ __ ] angel and
she's smart and just read up on money
alright she's also keeping in shape go
buy groceries don't become a tub of [ __ ]
you know she's basically without you
even realizing her possibly even her
she's laying down the gauntlet here
she's basically saying in her own cute
way I don't want to be married to some
fat broke trucker
alright so read up on money keep eating
your [ __ ] pears and fruit out there
and and you'll be fine alrighty there
you go alright
- ating name hey Bill my girl was
thinking about type of hyphenating did I
say hyperventilating earlier I can't
even remember five seconds ago I'm just
sleepy my girl was thinking of
hyphenating her name when we get married
I'm not some archaic patriarchal nutcase
but I think the whole concept is
absolutely ridiculous for one reason
first of all I love that if you if you
even disagree with some [ __ ]
horseshit a woman's gonna do at this
point you always have to say no I'm not
some caveman so anyways goes I think
it's absolutely ridiculous for one
reason say we have a daughter in our
our wants to be like mommy and get her
name - Aidid then she will have three
names if she has a daughter does the
same thing she will have four names
absolutely ridiculous your thoughts yeah
I would say that women hyphenating their
last names is basically the same as
that's like their prenup you know so
they can just drop you off you know if
you get divorced they can just sort of
chop you off like an appendix you know
like your this thing that isn't really
necessary but for some reason is still
there but you can live without it you
know look she's either marrying you or
she isn't okay cuz I gotta be honest
with you when I'm on the road and some
married woman with a hyphenated name
comes up to me I think I'm 50% in the
game
hey I'm not [ __ ] Sarah and Russell
I'm just trying to [ __ ] Sarah Ann why
don't you drop the Russell tonight baby
I'm just [ __ ] with you what do I
think about that um I don't know a woman
with a hyphenated last name to me that's
a red flag that's a red flag that says
to me that she doesn't want a husband
she wants a wife she's gonna be a
terrible mother and she's gonna focus on
her career that's what I think but then
again I'm ignorant you know wouldn't you
be Efrem Zimbalist jr. what is a good
[ __ ] hyphenated name doesn't that
chick who that raven-haired beauty who
married Michael Douglas isn't her name
like Ephraim zeta-jones Catherine
zeta-jones Douglas is that how she is or
she just kept her last name look at me
me and Nia ever get [ __ ] married she
goes I don't want to take your last name
or I want to hyphenate it I'd be like
you know it just you know don't [ __ ]
you know don't don't don't pander to me
here alright I just either you [ __ ]
taking my name of you're not you're not
doing this [ __ ] hyphenated [ __ ] keep
your own last name I don't give a [ __ ]
but our kids are gonna have my last name
because I'm the goddamn man and I'm
stronger than you that's how it's going
down I'm gonna be honest with you I
don't that hyphenating name thing is
[ __ ] weird to me I think you should
either just be look I'm not taking your
last name and just be done with it or
the hyphenating name is you know I
notice that a lot of chicks on Facebook
do that so they can get in touch with
guys they used to bang back in high
school in college so they can still be
found you know that's what I think
so there you go I think she's got a wild
streak in her
I don't think she's ready to settle down
she doesn't want that barn door to close
she'll go into the bum don't close that
door she's gonna start kicking um advice
hey Bill
I need some advice well I didn't give
you any what I think about it yeah I
think it is [ __ ] ridiculous
all right just say look if I'm gonna pay
for your [ __ ] life who's kidding who
that's what's gonna happen
you gotta pay for it one way or another
you are gonna pay for you're gonna have
most of the [ __ ] financial
responsibilities and you're gonna die
before she does that's basically how it
goes you know can you at least just take
my [ __ ] last name and act like you're
with me you [ __ ] unappreciative son
of a [ __ ] advice hey Bill I need some
advice badly I've got a [ __ ] delicate
situation I'm working with and I'm not
sure how to handle it I swear to god
this is how this guy's running I like
it's very conversational a little
pertinent first I'm 20 I'm a 20 year old
living with my parents my 21st is the
20th it's like a math problem if a train
leaves at 20 and the 21st is on the 20th
mid-april I plan on getting a vasectomy
I do not want advice about this well
you're gonna get judged what do you owe
you with those population people I
haven't gotten laid in about a year and
a half story last Friday the ninth there
was a party at a friend's house Kelly's
her parents were out of town and she was
a senior
what did I say her name is she of age
everyone was drinking a lot of fun
parties winding down and we go upstairs
Saturday morning I woke up in her bed we
go to breakfast had a real nice time
Saturday night I go over no party just
great sex I suggest a new position she
loses her mind says it was the best sex
of her life it's a great story so far
what could go wrong as we're cuddling
falling asleep Saturday into Sunday I
casually suggest that we should never
date and she completely agrees oh my god
this girl's a [ __ ] angel what could
go wrong right back step a little bit I
broke up with my very unserious
girlfriend and also a senior at the same
high school about two or three weeks ago
saying I want a more serious
relationship completely true the [ __ ]
challenges should I try and keep this
thing going
or quit while I'm ahead
the only potential downside is if word
gets out it would put a lot of strain on
the relationship with one of my
extremely good friends also my exbest
friend All Right see you banging your ex
best friend's girlfriend do I need to
read the rest of this yeah quit while
you're ahead dude unless you don't give
a [ __ ] about your best friend yeah
that's what I would do I will get the
[ __ ] out it let me let me reread that
again and guess I messed it I'm sorry
I'm [ __ ] half-asleep here the only
potential downside is if word gets out
you pull off with one of my extremely
good friends also my ex exes best friend
dude I can't do the math on that I'm too
[ __ ] tired it's you obviously you're
basically as far as I can tell there's a
cocktail party right around the corner
and you're on just the other side of the
wall banging the boss's girl this is
something going on it yeah dude get the
[ __ ] out pull the ripcord you banged her
it was great you're young it's gonna be
another
there's gonna be others don't worry
about it all right
all I can tell you this don't get a
vasectomy so you don't have to wear a
condom wear a condom all right
definitely do that you don't need that
[ __ ] all right you don't need any of
that [ __ ] that comes along with that
[ __ ] what are we up to guys can I tap
out early you guys ever go sick early on
a Friday you go home okay
tummy ache I want to go home right then
you go down to the local bar and you
start [ __ ] drinking right then all of
a sudden some girl in a jean [ __ ]
skirt starts dance a little
provocatively and next thing you know
yelling college boy you're next right
Lord was that an accused yes it was
Bon Jovi car everybody I'm blown hey you
know what I think it's time for
advertising oh great timing on this one
Oh amazon.com everybody if you're
thinking about buying any let me just
get through all the [ __ ] ads so we
can get back to the unbelievably
mediocre level of funny that I'm
bringing this week
Amazon calm everybody all right if you
think it'll go you thinking about buying
something nothing but if you're thinking
of buying something all right
on amazon.com and you'd like to
contribute to my podcast without it
costing you one more dime just go to
Amazon go go go a little back up go to
billboard.com click on the podcast page
you look on the right-hand side you'll
see an amazon.com banner all right
one for America one for UK and one for
Canada click on whatever country you're
in and the second you go there whatever
you buy they give me a little kick back
and I take 10% of the kick back and I
gave it to the Wounded Warrior Project
there you go bing-bang-boom
all done you donated to the podcast and
you helped out the wounded warriors then
I just realized you don't be [ __ ] up
is what if I got a Afghanistan
amazon.com and 10% of it went to the
wounded warriors you know I don't think
I'd sell anything over there gamefly.com
everybody it's the best way to rent
video games over 8,000 games no late
fees cancel anytime introducing
unlimited PC play Monday morning podcast
listeners you
15 day free trial 15 days of 8,000 games
free delivered to your house free right
to you PC okay all you do is go to game
flight WWE gamefly.com slash burr to
activate the special offer look at that
would you look at that because of me you
have the post office in your house okay
you're doing that while you're hitting
pause on 8,000 games
incredible and then if you go to buy a
[ __ ] beanie on amazon.com you can
help out the wounded warriors you know
and help me make my garage doors wider
everybody's winning here's something
that's really been doing well the skate
fenders people are buying them people
are sending me emails telling me they're
loving them telling their taking pucks
in their foot and they can barely even
feel it go to skate fender calm and type
in the promotional code Bilborough all
lowercase no no space for five dollars
off skate fenders I highly recommend
them I'm playing hockey tomorrow night
I'm putting them on and I'm gonna be a
shot-blocking [ __ ] because I got
protection on my feet skate fender calm
all right there you go that's it for
those that's it for those and oh hey did
you see this [ __ ] did you see this [ __ ]
about that [ __ ] guy he was got that
you know he went over to he went over to
Uganda that guy koni koni 2012
you see that you see how quickly they
brought that guy down this guy shines a
light on the on himself first and
foremost and how he and his child are
dealing with it which was really bizarre
I mean I don't know about you guys but
it was enough for me to see the boy
soldier crying because he saw his
brother have his neck sliced right in
front of him you know and he goes from
that to be a now I'm going to sit my son
down and tell him about the it's like I
didn't even get it alright so anyways
this guy shines a light on this [ __ ]
that's going on over there and all of a
sudden everybody's in an uproar over
sudden everybody gives a [ __ ] about
Uganda and these boys
soldiers you know and all of a sudden
the United States government's going
dude we're fighting two wars we can't
even afford to fight one now this guy's
bringing this [ __ ] up gee wouldn't it be
nice if something [ __ ] happened that
would discredit him next thing you know
a couple days later hey this guy
connected with the film from that Kony
2012 gets caught jerking off in public
was that the only guy who found that
unbelievably [ __ ] convenient I didn't
buy it for a second in fact I tweeted
you know back in the day they used to
assassinate you now they just do this
you don't I mean if they can make it
look like we landed on the moon in 1969
you don't think that they they can make
you anybody they want make it look like
you're rubbing one out in the [ __ ]
parking lot I don't buy it
what that [ __ ] douchebag was doing
not douchebag that [ __ ] self-serving
[ __ ] there we go that's what I was
trying to say what he was doing what
that film was he was putting pressure on
the United States to go over there and
[ __ ] somehow insert themselves into
that situation which would have cost a
ton of [ __ ] money you know but there's
no way to be like eh [ __ ] those boy
soldiers you know because of the the way
the coup because of what it says in our
pamphlet you know give a [ __ ] or you're
weak give us your poor and we'll exploit
the [ __ ] out of them and let him die of
tuberculosis in a damp apartment and
then years later whoever made the most
amount of money gets a statue made out
of them that's all in our thing so we
can't look the other way with these
[ __ ] boy soldiers so what's the
easiest thing to do just just make that
guy look like a freak show first of all
who hasn't jerked off in a parking lot
honestly you know who hasn't done that
you know you're right you [ __ ] girl
goes in to exchange something you're
sitting there you're bored you can't get
any radio reception cuz you know it's
back in the day just say yeah I'm bored
right you got a girl in your life so you
know there's gonna be some sort of
napkins in the car what are you gonna do
right you got the captain's chairs no
one can see you he's taking forever yeah
what if I rub one out
right yet that that that that but now
everybody's got a [ __ ] camera you
know you know it's amazing is that
everybody hasn't got caught jerking off
in public at this point everybody's got
a camera in their their cell phone what
I'm trying to say people is I don't buy
it
and it doesn't matter I don't give a
[ __ ] whether the guy from Kony was
jerking off in a parking lot or not that
doesn't change whether or not there's be
soldiers in Uganda but what's great is
is then the conversation switches from
what's going on over there - whoa what's
this guy doing easy rubbing his dick
like we all do
and then everybody would be like yeah
but we don't do it in public
oh so what that makes you better doesn't
make you better it just makes you more
considerate doesn't it I mean if you had
two people and they'll both shooting
heroin and one person had the decency to
do it in their house and the other
person does it out in public at the end
of the day you're both drug addicts so
if you're really gonna sit there and
[ __ ] on this guy for jerking off then
you would have to basically be not
jerking off at all right ladies and
gentlemen of the jury I'm asking you to
look into your hearts if you have not
rubbed one out let he who is not rubbed
one out in some sort of pump no you
never jerked off at work god I'm [ __ ]
bored
excuse me Ling go to the bathroom maybe
they think I'm taking a [ __ ] standing up
right come on if you're a guy in your
arms are long enough at some point
you've jerked off in some place where
you shouldn't have you jerked off to
somebody you shouldn't have you've done
it we've all been there who gives a [ __ ]
there's still boys fighting and wars
over there so you know if you want to
help out help out if you don't don't but
don't let some guy rub one out in a
parking lot
change your mind either way you know
what they're doing right now that doing
what women do when they argue when they
start to lose
is they bring up other [ __ ] and they
spin it into a different room and next
thing you know you're arguing a whole
different argument an argument that they
wanted you to [ __ ] argue so they knew
that they could win rather than keeping
the argument on [ __ ] track of saying
listen sweetheart I don't like the way
you [ __ ] been dressing lately okay I
got in this relationship to treat you
like a piece of [ __ ] meat
all right lately you've been slacking
off I mean it just might wait maybe the
funnies on this side of the couch um
what else what do we got here come on
bill you got another 11 minutes huh you
know I feel like right now like if I was
in the Tour de France I would actually I
would be in the Pyrenees right now all
right and my podcast is that one bald
[ __ ] with the bracelet and he
just looked back at me to see how I'm
doing he's seen my [ __ ] mouth hanging
open and now he's going into [ __ ]
second gear and I'm gonna lose his stage
okay except the Lance Armstrong is my
[ __ ] podcast this week if he didn't
get the metaphor was that a metaphor it
wasn't a simile simile is like her as
alright my podcast is like I always want
to say Greg LeMond what a douche that
guy is Greg LeMond I still can't get
over how a talked trash about Lance
[ __ ] all worth whatever the [ __ ] his
name is what is it Lance what lent Lance
Whitaker the only one seven bike races
built what the [ __ ] you ever done
did I even win a bike race in my
childhood you know I tried to beat my
brother one time in a bike race and that
[ __ ] always beat me he had big
legs you know and I had little legs
little [ __ ] legs and our driveway was
a hill and so you know and we lived on
this busy street so we'd always have to
[ __ ] stop and then you know look both
ways and then cross the [ __ ] Street
so from a dead stop I can have a good I
can have a beat this son of a [ __ ] so
one day we're racing home and I come up
with a brilliant [ __ ] idea and like
it's second
I know what I'll cross while we're
racing when he goes to stop I'll be
already going up the driveway and I'll
get to beat him and his [ __ ] Bo
Jackson thighs right up the goddamn
driveway and I swear to God I turned
around and I looked evidently I didn't
look well enough and I [ __ ] pulled
out right in front of a jeep and all I
heard was boom right next thing you know
I'm [ __ ] upside down and I vaguely
remember seeing the bumper and feeling
the heat of the engine and uh and then
like I don't know like two seconds later
I was opened my eyes and I was laying
across the yellow double line on the
road I was out for like literally like
[ __ ] five seconds long like because
by the time I stood up to get out of the
street the guy in the Jeep had already
got out this big son of a [ __ ] and he
was crying gone and he came up he's like
I'll buy you a new bike my bike was all
mangled
and all I was thinking was my dad's
gonna [ __ ] kill me for [ __ ] up my
bike cuz that's how it was in the 70s
all right
I know if that happened to a kid
nowadays my parents would have sued the
guy in the Jeep for everything he was
[ __ ] worth and then bought me a
bicycle made out of gold and that guy's
401k plan right but this was the
seventies people didn't sue people
yelled at kids for being dumb when they
did dumb [ __ ] so I was like oh my god
they're gonna [ __ ] kill me my bike's
all [ __ ] mangled and then I went to
the hospital on taxi cab all right I
told this story before I remember that I
thought like I hit right on the side of
the [ __ ] head it happened on a
Wednesday I remember happened on a
Wednesday cuz then I didn't have to go
to school
the guys say to go to school for the
rest of the week so I got Thursday
Friday Saturday Sunday off and all it
was [ __ ] up about me was on the side
of my head but you put your fingers on
the side of your temples right now right
and bite down on your molars you doing
that I know you feel that little thing
that goes in and out that's right where
I got hit so it hurt to chew
so for four days ie with a little spoon
and I didn't know I was just such it was
[ __ ] awesome I didn't have to fake
sick I don't have to pretend that I was
sick and for four days which is a
goddamn eternity I got the [ __ ] chill
out 54 minutes um I don't know how you
[ __ ] people do this it's just like
this is like your workweek isn't it just
staring at the [ __ ] clock hey you
know I always make fun of how Bon Jovi
can somehow sellout giant stadiums in
New Jersey but for some reason can't
sell out a [ __ ] Denny's and in Oregon
I don't know if that's true I just like
[ __ ] on him somebody wrote and said
hey Bill I love the podcast I know when
you're vexing questions of our ages why
the [ __ ] is Bon Jovi so popular in New
Jersey I get that they're from from
there but Giants Stadium anyways he goes
I'm a u.s. servicemembers stationed
overseas in Germany when I first moved
here two years ago I saw a Volkswagen in
my town with a Bon Jovi sticker on the
side of the car I thought holy [ __ ] that
is one dedicated fan and wouldn't be
funny if VW really made a Bon Jovi
edition of the vehicle well I started
seeing the car elsewhere in Germany and
finally I googled it it's real the
attached photo is a picture I took on
the base of a VW Bon Jovi yeah and it's
not a sticker it's literally like the
emblem like on the side of your car if
it says Prius or Monte Carlo right
there's that funny that Chevy named that
car in Monte Carlo I've never seen Monte
Carlo Monte Carlo that's in France and
it has like [ __ ] yeah that's all the
Illuminati money and in America it's
some shitty icing that shades a
good-looking car
back in the 80s it was but come on you
know there was a poor man's caddy it's a
poor man's Buick anyways they actually
it's it's the yeah like like what it's
it's the make not to make
not to make what if the [ __ ] is it they
say make type and I'm [ __ ] though I'm
sleepy it's on the side of the goddamn
[ __ ] car we got a picture of it
everybody you know what I feel like
right now I feel like one of those guys
who gives those double-decker tour bus
guys you know and I don't know [ __ ]
about the city and I don't give a [ __ ]
and somebody hooked me up with the job
that's what I feel like anyways that's
the podcast for this week everybody I
apologize I take full responsibility
this I'm gonna do this like when an
athlete blows a game and he knows the
press is gonna trash him so he just
jumps on the [ __ ] grenade before they
throw it in his face
I take full responsibility for that law
said I didn't I didn't get it done
I didn't get it done all right shows I
have coming up
alright you [ __ ] I'm gonna be at the
DuPont Theatre Wilmington Delaware on
March 30th our March 31st 31st 35th
Jesus Ben wake up March 31st the
cavalcade of humor continues when Bill
Byrne shows up to Massachusetts on Bill
burr shows up to the Music Hall in Troy
New York on April 1st albeit the
Tarrytown Music Hall with Paul virzi
Paul virzi New Jersey's own Paul virzi
who's a he's a Jets and a Giants fan
he's one of those guys whoever's winning
he becomes the fan of them April 27th
I'm doing a college gig and this is open
to the public this is very rare this is
a situation that does not occur a lot
hence a rare situation I'm gonna be at
Concord College in Concord New Hampshire
all right on April 27th and I have all
the links here on Billboard Calm you
just click on shows and then you click
on the Go button next to the gig you
want to go to and next thing you know
you're going to the [ __ ] show unless
your girl gets sick and doesn't want to
go and then you got to eat the [ __ ]
tickets when you're resent her when she
falls asleep you give give her paper
cuts with the tickets between her toes
June 15th 16th and 17th I want to be in
San Jose California
no I'm going to be at the improv San
Jose California June 15th through the
17th and if that's if that city isn't
enticing enough you could then like the
Grateful Dead follow me to another
luxurious City a place called Ontario
California part of the Inland Empire
that conquered the middle region of
Southern California hundreds of years
ago gonna be at the Ontario improv on
June 29 30th and July 1st those gonna be
great shows because I hate that City so
I will be extra kunti and probably a lot
funnier than I am on this podcast and
the last one I have for you fall you
white trash people anybody out there got
a mullet I got to I got back-to-back
back-to-back now
July 13th 14th and 15th I'm at The
Improv in West Palm Beach all right
and if that isn't white trash enough for
you I'm gonna be in Orlando Florida home
of Disney World
the Epcot Center and the day after pill
the morning after what do they call it
Orlando Florida
I'm gay at the Orlando improv September
7th 8th and 9th and finally I'll be at
the Brea improv September 21st 22nd and
23rd and I know what you're thinking
Wild Bill those are a lot of club dates
there's a lot of shows you're gonna do
there you're kind of [ __ ] old what
are you doing all those shows for well
I'll tell you why everybody I'm building
up my new hour all right I'm building up
my new I was supposed to learn how to
write a [ __ ] motorcycle today but it
was supposed to rain so they everybody
cancelled it so hopefully next week I'll
have some stories about me trying to
learn how to ride a motorcycle or
something hopefully I'll have something
remotely remotely funny for you people
okay that's the podcast for this week
everybody and I think it's very fitting
for me to end with the exact amount of
energy I have right now in this tone of
voice
all right Oh YouTube video of the week
for drummers out there why don't you
guys look up the Dru groove applied to
the modern drum set love all these
videos up on the
uh I'm sorry Dilbert calm on the podcast
page there we go I'm actually doing this
right now with my eyes closed okay I'm
trying to think of an artist who used to
perform with his eyes closed Mitch
Hedberg
the great Mitch Hedberg so that's
sacrilegious because I'm about 190
a--the his funny is that son of a [ __ ]
and speaking of funny Patrice O'Neal
everybody I know I mentioned it a while
back I want to thank all you guys who
went out and downloaded mr. P his CD was
number one on iTunes and generated a lot
of money for his his mom and if he can't
buy any comedy or anything like that I'd
appreciate if you do that if you would
buy mr. P I told you guys eventually I
was going to tell some stories about him
but I'm still still stunned by that
whole situation and I don't want to talk
about it so at some point I will but
anyways that's the podcast for this week
please download mr. P amazon.com all
that type of [ __ ]
and that's it go [ __ ] yourselves have a
good week don't take any [ __ ] yeah
people are still boy soldiers in Uganda
whether or not that guy's rubbin one out
or opening his ass for the world to see
don't ever forget that don't lose sight
of what the real story is okay that is
all good night and God bless the United
States of America
you